this might be the most I've ever been on
this so Wow a shocking elimination
leaves the judges completely stunned and
could pop music royalty be behind a mask
I like big butts and I cannot lie it's
all coming up live on unmasking the
masked singer
first off that impression was really
good Nicole another Brittany
impersonator did you think was go went
home definitely the bear anyway very
very surprising so take a look at the
first elimination believe what you think
holy snap
oh my goodness I mean I feel like week
after week there are so many stars that
go on this show that we expect actors
athletes
singers I really don't expect too many
politicians to pop up on here
definitely not Sarah Palin I definitely
not Sarah Palin I think now is the time
for rebirth and if she wants to go out
and have fun the masked singer is a
hundred percent the place to do it and I
think my favorite moment was then
putting the glasses on her when she took
the head off like I mean I need to see
what's going she needed her vision yes
in case you missed it this was so epic
and iconic take a look my voice just
doesn't sound like what I would assume
Sarah Palin to sound like I mean I guess
we've never really heard Sarah Palin's
sing right yeah I've heard to give
plenty of speeches never singing
especially that song right right a very
unexpected song choice which was a
brilliant move on her part of course
we'll really quickly talk you through
some of the clues that sort of gave this
away let's throw up the elephants so in
2010 our girls Sarah she launched the
pink elephant movement to promote and
raise funds for female Republican
candidates so that was one thing that
kind of gave it away I also want to talk
about the octo bear calendar so it
wasn't just October it was October and
if you notice on Saturday it said live
well Sarah appeared on an episode of SNL
with Tina Fey her famous impersonator in
October of 2008 so that was a very like
nuanced clue but if you know you know
and then my last and final one I'm gonna
call out is the hockey skates so I
thought this was maybe Candace Cameron
Bure she's married to a hockey player
which I know Jenny mentioned but no of
course it's Sarah she had the very
famous quote at the RNC in 2008 she said
I love those Hockey Moms you know they
say the difference between a hockey mom
and a pit bull is lipstick so most
iconic quote correct and of course I
believe the judges threw a few names out
there and we might have our first
reality check of the night hmm so one
like I don't know Tonya Harding
that is all I can think of right now and
there's a very hidden clue inside the
trunk is a tire iron gave me up last
night hey if this really was Sonia
harder you would say that they're born
to hunt baby you got to do what you got
to do to win but do you know who else
has to kiss Britney Spears bark it could
be Britney because if it was Britney and
she's saying baby got back it would be
like I like big butts and I cannot laugh
Nicole again the impersonation spot on
Jenny's pure disapproval was also one of
my favorite moments from tonight yes and
as in official Britney stands I would
know immediately if that was our girl
Britney I know that's correct well we
asked you guys over on entertainment
tonight's Twitter who you were most
excited to see tonight in the
performances and I am surprised you guys
were really pushing for the Swan not as
many excited for the Rhino but a lot of
you were excited for that night angel
and listen she gave love a bad name but
she gave us a badass performance take a
look
[Applause]
first of all great song choice I love
this I'm honestly a little terrified of
this costume but I will tell you who I
can surely say I think it is going with
kandi Burruss from the Real Housewives
songwriter producer reality TV star
she's truly done it all by this point
and I'll tell you I we saw a few door
numbers during her clue package there
was a four a five and a six all three of
those yep there we go so they were shown
at different points but a four five and
a six
aw I made an appearance she has written
a song called four five six so quite
literally quite literally four five six
on top of that we saw they key with the
number two well she was a house guest on
the second American season of Celebrity
Big Brother she also joined the Real
Housewives of Atlanta during the second
season and number two really important
to her TV career as well as that the
third clue that gave it away for me it
was we saw some looks like granny's
maybe dancing yeah dancing granny's well
old lady gang is actually the restaurant
that she owns along with her family
members her mother her her sisters
everyone's a part of that I love that
she is a true and tried entrepreneur
yeah completely and I think something
she tried throwing us a little bit with
was a fake British accent yeah stage I
was like who could this be but she's so
talented I feel like it's so easy for
her to just throw on an accent like
something that is completely different
from who she is but I don't think we're
buying it exactly and if you haven't
heard her sing before she was part of
the girl group escape as on top of that
she also has a Grammy Award yeah for
helping write the song no scrubs TLC
iconic pop yeah so she is a huge player
in the music industry and I'm happy to
see her sing on the show hopefully I
feel like it's such a natural fit for
her being such a huge part of the music
industry before we saw her transition
into reality TV and those vocals
impressed everybody yeah really truly
Slade great purse great first
performance our next performer took us
out of this world
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a country crooner a country crooner and
Twitter was all in agreement I honestly
saw one name being thrown out there and
I am agreeing with it for Hunter Hayes
yeah Hunter Hayes I listen I am gonna
admit I'm not a huge country person I
and I'm not be there yet but I am going
with Hunter Hayes and I will tell you
why there were a few different clues
that stood out to me one of them being a
little strange but it was a skeleton
foot
well Hayes and singer Victoria Justice
actually contributed a duet to the
soundtrack of the 2011 remake of
Footloose which is fire a skeleton foot
but loose that was honestly the biggest
thing that stood out to me in the clue
package but we also heard him say
something on stage after his performance
take a look it connected you to the
astronaut well people say the sky's the
limit but when you're an astronaut this
guy is just the beginning and even
though I started at a young age I feel
like I'm just getting started
started at a young age obviously hunter
is someone who has he's still really
young today but I mean he got his start
years ago as a kid and you know I'm a
bachelor fan and he performed on an
episode of The Bachelor days a year and
I think he's really trying to do things
that take him out of that kid box and he
wants to be taken seriously like so many
people who go on the mess sing or do you
know be seen in a little different light
when I think and I think it's
interesting cuz a lot of people were
pointing out online it kind of sounded
like he was nervous almost in his voice
but then other people were chiming in
and saying that's actually just how he
sounds that's kind of the natural
vibrato of his voice which I totally
agree with if you listen to some live
performances it sounds a lot like that
so I'm sticking with Hunter Hayes here
1,000%
well our next performer was a dinosaur
which is kind of crazy to say but gave a
killer killer performance check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean I Stan Jojo see wha
that girl has so much energy and
charisma and that has got to be her my
vote is for sure Jojo see what as the
t-rex I Mingus is Austin just watching
that she's jumping around it so much I'm
not like the shoot dance that she was
doing yeah we have seen her do that
everywhere yeah I'm also going with Jojo
see you are okay let's break it all down
a little bit so the first clue that
really tipped me off was the north and
west
directions highlighted on that napkin
right there so if we can just kind of
show that napkin one more time you
notice there's the four directions but
only N and W were highlighted well okay
Jojo see WA is friends with quite
literally North West Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West's daughter they had a very
famous play date they hung out together
and you see all that slime on the screen
there
Jojo is famous for making slime so she
and North they make slime together I was
like okay this has got to be Jojo see WA
but if we need further confirmation we
saw some dinosaurs dancing and the t-rex
said in the clue package they were plot
that this person was plucked from
obscurity to dance with dozens of
creatures pure wetting the land
now of course Jojo got her start on
Dance Moms pirouette is a technical
dance term where you spin around in a
little circle so I was like okay this is
someone who definitely has dance
knowledge and got famous with a troupe
of people and then last but not least we
saw this u-shaped gold balloon with
three colorful stars on it so Jojo she
actually dropped a single last year
called
number one you always drop in those
motivational and inspirational bops and
then the stars are very like reminiscent
of the vibe of Jojo I mean look at her
jacket quite this just star
it's just glittery stars it's I love her
I think she's such a positive role model
and this show is again a really natural
fit for her she probably also wants to
be taken a little more seriously as you
know she's growing up and and I love it
I do you think I just love it like I
think the moment they give it away was
when she yelled and the performance and
she was like yeah if you've ever gone
down a Jojo see wha like black hole on
YouTube and just watched her videos and
like I have chances are you have heard
her scream that when she starts her
videos it's just another recognized
yeah you know actually someone called
out actually Maddie Ziegler one of the
judges said maybe it's Maddie Ziegler
but come on if you're a Jojo co-op and
you know this has to be Jojo see yes
well our next performer had a little
faith in all of us take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
have a little faith in me
[Music]
I think Nicole said it best
we definitely have a little faith in
this singer because that was a great
great performance and those vocals were
spot-on the entire way through I was
thrown at how tall the Rhinos presence
seems to be very - who's your best
guests so online agreed with me here
Twitter was really going for a country
person again we saw Hunter Hayes another
country star I am going with Trace
Adkins because he is the height of six
foot six oh you standing next to Nick
there he was tall this is definitely the
tallest performer the group like I said
Trace is six six but there was a few
other clues that sold it for me as well
we saw a few kind of magazine looking
covers one said anonymous living masked
quarterly yep you can see them here well
trace back in the day we also heard him
talk about football in the clue package
a little bit or saw the judges guest
football it was thrown out that this
could be a football player because of
the height well trace was an offensive
lineman at Louisiana Tech Bulldogs
football team he actually left the team
after his freshman season due to and due
to a knee injury that is some deep
research some deep research nice job
dream also the second clue we have here
we saw a drink picture a drink pitcher
something you would see almost like in a
bar well trace has been very open about
his relationship with alcohol
the singer doesn't feel any pressure to
drink these days and he has had two
stints in rehab 2001 and 2014 he is
sober these days and does talk about it
publicly yeah I think we heard that in
the clew package a bit how he's kind of
shying away from something that was
being forced upon him before that could
obviously lead to his sobriety and what
a cool message you know I feel like so
much of what we do here is we laugh and
we talked about how silly and outlandish
these performances are but if this is
Trace Adkins good for him for using this
platform to you know like someone at
home who might also be struggling with
those issues that like look I'm here and
I'm promoting it and it's okay and I
just want to let the world know that you
can overcome totally totally and that
was definitely a big part of this clue
package was overcoming we heard faith at
the end of the clue package as well and
we also saw a picture of the Grand Old
Opry if we can throw that up there he
was actually inducted in 2003 so that
makes a lot of sense there you go okay
let's get into our final character
[Music]
till you
[Music]
oh my goodness love it this is my
favorite performance of the night right
off the bat the clues screamed to me
jennifer Love Hewitt which Nicole guest
as well correct
Nicole has really been in sync with me
tonight it's not Britney Spears and it's
probably Jennifer Love Hewitt so I'm a
90s freak I love everything 90's and
jennifer Love Hewitt really embodies
that and let's go through the clue
package and what kind of dissect why a
lot of things point to the 90s so the
first clue we saw this ghost a ghost was
hanging like in the forest this was not
the 90s but we'll celebrate it anyways
Jennifer starred on the show ghost
whisperer so quite literally ghost the
second clue they gave it away was also
pretty literal like remember how we've
been talking to season about don't take
it so deep this one literal litter yeah
so we saw this this pool float right
here is a heart well Jennifer Love
Hewitt right that makes sense makes
perfect sense to me and then the last
clue that I want to talk about is this
megaphone and so I was like has this
person played a cheerleader in a movie
or something well here's here's my
rationale on the megaphone jennifer Love
Hewitt's starred in the iconic 90's
franchise I know what you did last
summer of course a horror movie which
was also alluded to in the clue package
she has this very famous scene in the
movie where she goes what are you
waiting for huh so it's like she's
literally projecting her voice screaming
[ __ ]
yes and hence the megaphone what do you
think I'm going with you on that one I
think it was a great guest by Nicole we
also heard a few other names Sarah
Michelle Gellar was getting thrown out
there a lot online I could kind of see
it going that way as well but I think
the clues they're pointing more to
Jennifer Love Hewitt for now there's one
other thing I want to point out about
Jennifer Love Hewitt
she was on the show or it still is on
the shows on the show she was on the
show nine-one-one your favorite show
favorite crime drama show yes it is on
Fox so she's already in the Fox family
it would make sense to do a little cross
promo there yeah I could I could
definitely see that and I think the
voice does sound like her to 100% we
know she is a singer she had a singing
career so of course we want to talk all
about it with you guys let us know your
thoughts your comments who could be
behind these groups see masks let us
know if you think we're onto something
there and we will be back next week to
talk all about the group C playoffs yes
yeah we'll see you soon who is that it
was that
[Music]